otro cambio en el gabinete de perú tomó
juramento avelino guillén el tercer
ministro del interior en menos de 100
días del gobierno de pedro castillo si
puro
bienvenido apreciado avelino guillén tu
conocimiento experiencia y trayectoria
nos permitirán seguir luchando contra la
delincuencia y además estaremos más
cerca de cumplir los anhelos profundos
de nuestro pueblo el nuevo ministro fue
el encargado de acusar en 2009 al ex
presidente alberto fujimori por crímenes
de lesa humanidad y llega al cargo en
sustitución de louis barranzuela quien
renunció tras ser acusado de hacer una
fiesta de hallowen en medio de las
reflexiones impuestas por la pandemia
por su propia cartera no ha sido un
mandato fácil para el presidente pedro
castillo que asumió el poder el 28 de
julio de este año la oposición y su
propio partido han ejercido presión
desde el congreso en medio de la
inestabilidad política del primer
ministro y de bellido renunció obligando
a dimitir a siete ministros por ser el
jefe de gabinete el nuevo nombramiento
se da en momentos en que el congreso
peruano controlado por una oposición
debe decidir si le da el voto de
confianza a los ministros del castillo
sin este voto el gabinete no puede
mantenerse en funciones en medio de la
crisis política el presidente decidió
militarizar las calles para ayudar a
luchar contra los altos índices
delictivos la medida ha causado
controversia y advertencia de organismos
internacionales como human rights watch
y amnistía internacional